la france pourra-t-elle compter sur le
soutien militaire américain dans le
sahel
l'interrogation demeure pour paris après
l'élection de john dryden
à peine nommé le nouveau chef du
pentagone n'a pas apaisé les inquiétudes
de la ministre française des armées lors
d'un entretien téléphonique avec
florence parly lloyd austin n'a apporté
aucune réponse concrète sur les
intentions de l'armée américaine en
afrique
le ministre n'a pris aucun engagement
dans un sens ou dans un autre
mais il a évidemment exprimer sa
reconnaissance pour le travail que la
france accomplis en termes de lutte
contre le terrorisme
lloyd austin veut examiner l'ensemble de
la posture militaire des etats-unis dans
le monde avant de prendre des décisions
spécifiques dans le sahel les états unis
apportent à l'opération barkan leurs
capacités de renseignement ainsi qu'en
soutien logistique pour des dépenses qui
avoisine les 45 millions de dollars par
an il ya un an l'administration trump
avait fait part de son intention de
réduire la présence américaine en
afrique mais dans les faits cela n'a pas
été le cas
dans ce contexte la france prépare
l'organisation du prochain g 5 celle qui
réunira mi-février les pays de la région
lutte contre les groupes jihadistes pour
préparer cette rencontre emmanuel macron
a reçu cette semaine à l'elysée le
président de transition malien benneteau
le président français a suscité
l'inquiétude de ses partenaires
africains après avoir annoncé son projet
de réduire les efforts militaires de
paris dans la région
plus de cinq mille soldats français sont
déployés sur place dans le cadre de
l'opération barkan le maintien de ce
dispositif sera l'un des enjeux majeurs
de la réunion qui se tiendra les 15 et
16 février prochain dans la capitale
tchadienne n'djamena